hey how about we're in zoo that time
this guy
clearly on the spectrum come we're on
the bench thumbs up
he stared at me like this and at first i
was like all right well here we are and
then i'm like talking to someone he's
still there i go
what's up man and he goes i need a bench
i go
well cool we're using this one he goes
right right right
and he just keeps standing i go what's
up man and he goes
you tom hardy i go
that's i and then i go you ever seen
tomorrow
already small dude i'm not tom hardy he
goes
cool and walks off and then i looked at
mark and toronto
hey is that what the [ __ ] was that man i
think you can come back
yeah yeah so you you know a guy and i'm
not going to say his name
because it's not a great story about him
but but he didn't know
but he's a hothead he's a hothead and
he'll punch in face
and uh but he's a good person but a guy
we're at a bar
and this is in venice and a guy with
with a
like he's holding on to the dishes like
the thing with it for the dirty dishes
yeah
little glasses yeah and he's any and he
walks by
and he and he kind of like he's got one
of those eyes and he's just looking at
my friend and he kind of just
bumps him and my friend goes like that
and he's going [ __ ] whatever
and then the guy comes back and looks at
my friend
and goes move he just goes move
he's got the busboy right he's the bus
boy and i mean i might have told you
that story i don't know
so my friend my friend goes
what move you move [ __ ]
and the guy goes move again
and now my friend goes all right
let's do this and he's gonna fight the
guy
the best one the busboy who is a little
bit big though it looks looks kind of
tough
and he's got a neck and he's kind of
looking at him like this two
probably having a day well here it gets
better so my friend now is
now the guy kind of moves over he kind
of moves over and puts the
he puts the tray down no he doesn't yes
he does so now
now i have another friend who's there
who's that dirty
that would be good no instead he stands
like this like the reddy
so my friend who who will
fight goes let's go and he he starts to
come at him
and my friend is rather muscular and
rather scary and this guy is standing
there and not
backing down while this dude's on the
clock while he's on the clock he's not
backing out he's like
he's working overtime tonight and i
don't know what's going on
but he he says he said i said to move
again the busboy said that he said i
said to move against this guy
so my other friend is your size actually
even a little bigger
who is it i don't want to say his name
his i know he played basketball in
college he's a very big guy
you don't know him oh yeah he grabs my
friend who's very strong but not
as big and kind of holds on to him like
this
and i'm now in front of my friend
because my friend's going to do
something and get in
serious trouble guess what guess what
happens
the other bartender comes running around
and goes dude dude dude
he's on the spectrum he's autistic he
doesn't know what you're doing he
doesn't know what you're doing
well my friend also has a child who
happens to have that condition
so the guy didn't know what was going on
he was looking and he got to pick up
social cues
he got stuck in move move he got stuck
and so now now my friend goes now my
friend is like and
i think my friend goes oh no and now
he now he doesn't know what to do and
the guy they usher the guy in the back
and he's all messed up
so my friend of course now goes over and
goes hey i want to be your friend i'm
sorry i want to be your friend and he
hugs him
he no he's fine he's
so he held on to him he held on to him
and he
and and now they're friends and he made
friends and he wouldn't leave aside all
[ __ ] night
he almost beat his ass i know that's the
other but this guy was big and this guy
was staring at him like this still
i thought he was coming out you're
fighting who are your friends you're
still too old to be active the whole
thing's a problem
even if that kid wasn't on the spot i
will say this
i'll say this the way he did it looked
like he was
literally trying to fight he did but
think my thing is where he goes through
my he's a bus boy he's probably having
one hell of a day
he's like dude just get the [ __ ] out but
it was so weird though it was so con
confrontational and all he was trying to
do is he didn't know how to go this way
he didn't know so
i i'm what i'm saying is that you can
see how that kid could get himself in
trouble
yes because if you didn't know he was
standing there ready he was standing
like that it's been funny he was doing
it it's been funny
if your boy came at that i came back to
him the kid beat the [ __ ] out of him and
then you found out he's on the spectrum
that's that's the that's that
well i don't know if you noticed with
that guy that came up to you like when
he was at
when he was sitting at the bench he was
like kind of like
rocking and stuff that's why i figured i
was like it was like he's probably oh no
he was cool i talked to him
i talked to him after that yeah yeah
because i was like you ever seen tom
hardy and he was like
and then he went sat down and then after
i'm like dude tom hardy's like 5
8 and he's like what yeah he's not a big
big guy
so one of he's like he uses baini looks
huge i know that's the movies but
he's kind of a small yes he didn't so
the thing about the [ __ ]
don't ever come with an open hand you
just gave him a
paint brush the [ __ ] out of his face no
i still see him in there
yeah yeah he'll come here the thing
about autistic children a lot of times
is that when they miss cues they can't
it's really subtle they don't they don't
read
cues and then they get lonely and then
they're alone and they don't know why
it's funny
i was at a birthday party kid's birthday
party one tiger's friends
and i was talking to dad and he go i go
oh you know everyone's
you know they start at this preschool
and then everyone goes their own way to
their different schools yeah in
california it's a nightmare you gotta
apply to schools like in the colleges
yeah and so like the
x-men mutant school all the kids are are
geniuses literally to get in school you
have to have a certain iq
i go damn literally to get in school you
have to have a certain iq
i go damn she she got the iq test goes
yup
162 iq and i was like isn't elon musk
like 155 or something like 160.
he goes yeah holy [ __ ] i'd be stoked man
he goes
stoked but comes with a different set of
problems what do you mean he goes
well like her social skills aren't great
so and then also she's so smart
like it it's tough to communicate with
her do you know what happened she was
like she's on a different frequency
how's he go she on a spectrum he goes
he goes i don't think it's that because
she's really good with her sister
he was like she's just moving at her
minds at a million miles an hour
so she just it's different so like and i
go with her signs early goes
yeah like she started full sentences
when she was one and then uh like
we'll show her something like soccer or
something like that and she can
get it down like that like her
athleticism and her download of
like the that's pretty good yeah he was
like so i think sports
because she's tall and athletic he's
like wow she's gonna be really good at
sports too
yeah because they say that a lot of
times when you see a kid who's in
college at 14
it statistically doesn't work out for
them as smart as they are
that what happens is they don't they
they don't know how to socialize they
don't learn those crucial skills
so what happens is yeah you either go
into something they a lot of times they
become hermits
they so they've done these studies on
the smartest this one guy was speaking
when he was six months old something
crazy he's the smartest guy
they you know iq and stuff like that and
he he didn't know how to
um deal with people who said no he just
never learned that so he would just quit
and run away
and so he never actually even went to
college because
of uh there was a some kind of a weird
glitch in the
administration things like [ __ ] it and
so he ended up just being a hermit and
no but then some of those geniuses
come up with an app some of them are
elon musk
yeah and then they're like oh cool i
don't speak great to women
i don't know how [ __ ]
bill gates is a very strange dude
apparently strange or
awesome the more i read about my keys
pretty cool
yeah they're like yeah he used to throw
these extravagant parties at his house
all these women i'm like oh oh you
talking about the the nerd who never got
chicks in high school
yeah created [ __ ] microsoft and all
of a sudden he's a billionaire
and he can finally get women that guy
let me ask you this
yeah and let me ask you this like if
your girl stepped out on you with bill
gates
would you be that threatened would you
be a little bit yeah you wouldn't
you was like babe bill sent a g6
that's fine i'm a jet i know you're on
southwest yeah but i'm gonna jump in
this g6
well i'm gonna fly to seattle i'll be
back tonight he's gonna send a
helicopter like you can't compete with
but i'd also be like is there an extra
seat for me because i'm not
you trying to kick it i'm just not that
impressed like you're not doing anything
in bed i think it's not going to ruin it
it's not going to be like knocking the
boots
you're saying he can't be great in bed i
look i
know like he's not yeah
but if she left you for lebron james
you'd be like i i get
what happens when you're naked with him
there's a there's a carnal like a desire
i can't compete with
with bill it's like warm cheese or this
you know yeah i don't know maybe i
wouldn't be as worried no with bill
gates